CNN published an article which according
to their caption on Twitter purports to
show that quote advantages of being
raised by a single mother outweigh
expectations and Outlast childhood
embarrassment advantages roughly 24
million or one-third of All American
children under age 18 are living with an
unmarried parent and 81 percent of those
single-parent homes are headed by among
the number of kids being raised by
mostly single moms has more than doubled
between 1968 and 2017. and it's
catastrophic we've been running this
social experiment for decades to see if
fathers are expendable for children
individually and Society generally and
we've gotten an answer to that question
the answer is the one that's the
moderately perceptive people decades ago
already knew and warned about the answer
is no every child has a mother and a
father which means that they need
a mother and a father they may get by
with only one parent but it's not ideal